[Music]
how's it going bros my name is beard
welcome back to afraid of monsters oh
what's that
all right chop these boxes I am in shop
but if I can have it chop chop drugs
stop don't touch the toughest on top no
no George
doctor doctor stop stop stop I don't
know dogs got damn tough tough tough
tough tough is he dead
yeah he did Jesus Christ Ruben why would
he do that why we discussed this Ruben
Jesus guys forget I love top top top top
top top top top top top top top top top
no drugs
damn it my dogs women top top top um
stop stop where my drugs series is I
hide yeah duck duck Duck Duck Duck all
right which one is it for [ __ ] out one
deagle mo all right
whatever whatever it's cool it's called
adapter my rabbit up gotta reload Rubel
we can be friends alright
haha he thought we could be friends
alright alright top top top top top hey
I don't know
alright a lot of people having say like
well it's you so good at aiming or what
I don't know I'm not it's not like i'm
tryharding for people here to like hey
elevator I live a levator all right
that's clickety clack hey I'm going up
or down
hey I love going up can still you whip
it yep
I love going up jumper just a top top
top top dub dub dub dub dub dub dub dub
dub dub top top top top duck Duck Duck
oh oh oh it's a [ __ ] bag boy alright
look it's got the [ __ ] damn you dog
I get off me Jesus Christ it's so
[ __ ] creepy
why does he have a bag on his [ __ ]
head top top top top top top top top top
top hey dogs it's Christmas
hello Christmas alright let's go here
okay well you got this nor from lamb
Oh girls come in I kill you I [ __ ]
kill you hey what is this a shop it I
can't shop hey maybe I can top top top
top top duck duck Duck Duck Duck Duck
top top top top top top I can jump baby
top right what's the point of this loan
top top top top
they don't stop top duck duck Duck Duck
no really why why this is matrix he's
crying for Emma
so dark this ski I don't like dark Nicky
maybe back in the elevator hey what the
[ __ ] am i this elevator
ah chop chop chop chop this up to top
the top Chuck hey more ammo sweet
where do we go now down the end top top
top top da da oh come on why would I
wanna go down again I don't on the
stones it's all something I missed I am
the funnest person this is a French
person tag icon boy I am a French puzzle
I am hey dude I was like all right
that's cool that's cool all those like
anyway I don't trust the sun's to come
from over here come on
come on Kim in alright alright let's get
back up I guess [ __ ] I won my deep legal
it's so awesome one shot killing blow
their like flew back oh this is me shoot
it back okay that sounds more like me
throwing up or something I don't know
can I go or what I'm stuck I'm stuck bad
I'm sorry
tap tap tap tap tap tap tap
not even chopping wood saving out lady
ah [ __ ] I'm stuck first bug in the game
though and what's up with that
alright whatever save there anyway ah
Jesus crying squeeze my friend oh wow
how am i battery cuz my [ __ ]
flashlight was on - that's not good
fight one that not good for a walk yeah
alright chop chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop
please be drugs alright it's [ __ ]
ammo right don't let it be dark no
[ __ ]
hello Oh Oh someone load me into
contract harder why didn't I go offline
I know I always forget why do I even
bother
okay they're teaming up on me let's go
not very fun forever indoors that's what
you get bro let's chop some [ __ ] more
chop chop chop drugs
oh god damn whatever I mean right okay i
reversed
haha hey I saw it I saw it on my bicep
if I shoot something over here maybe buy
that lie back anyway
hey it's a lies for sure no there's
nothing
maybe fractured that or that or that I'm
just wasting our time well you're
wasting ammo bearded boy I don't know
I'm sorry
hey wait okay you got through the crotch
jump I love to crotch him
let's do that hey and then I jump here
maybe I don't know don't judge Wow
maybe I can chop chop that's high jump
Hey Oh I'll steam hot steam that good
friend one all right let's do this
I'm out of flashlights it's cool and now
we jump
I don't know cuz I can't [ __ ] see
anything don't fall down boy [ __ ] all
right it's cool
where is it [ __ ] there all right
can I walk you out I can walk here
ah goddamn it
ah [ __ ] my outsole Jesus Christ it's not
easy
[ __ ] steam is burning my ass why
would they burn my hair anything my my
uh I'm getting I'm pissed off now this
is my pissed face if you see me on the
street walking with this face you better
run buddy actually probably that I'm not
that danger all right
[ __ ] all right it's cool if I shout -
okay I appreciate appreciate that I'm
gonna have to health and I'd [ __ ]
steam whoever [ __ ] died from Steam
please tell me someone tell me one
[ __ ] person who died from steam tell
me I okay I did funny huh you think
you're clever huh your fingers glad that
all right now see these face I got them
I got stuck again
oh wow I feel like a [ __ ] today
really really fail I written all over me
it's okay would you chopped up
you know I don't fail this much usually
right right right
please just say yes all right [ __ ] I've
had to do with this little again all
right [ __ ] I've got that huh huh it's
easy if I can't see you all right again
and then here f6 like a [ __ ] I
don't know why I didn't do this before
let's do this crouch jumping thing or
whatever so I'm like oh yeah I can old
shift to be slower I forgot
I hope not a lot of people will come to
know about it like hey there can the
whole ship
alright f6 [ __ ] I'll I heard
monsters huh what's that coming from my
relevant god damn you scared me Ruben I
can't click these
all right this run past f6 and then this
run past I guess we can throw back yeah
so Klaus need my drugs
thank you if anyone's not familiar with
the story I think we're name is hey I
want to see what our name is it's right
here
David leather Hoff how about Turkish
Pete I'm gonna Peter is that worry David
leather ha change his name to dervish
computer be that people name bro
alright we're drug addict and this poor
just take some drugs or whatever and we
see these ah goddammit [ __ ] I don't
know jump pipes like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
but that's cool
all right I think we're good finally
click that I did it I did you just you
just watch you watch girl thank you for
the support I want to thank my fans my
girlfriend my loving my loving and I
don't know I don't have any ah ah
alright I just want to go home alright
is it cool [ __ ] you [ __ ] all of you
ah mother penis mother from mother
effing penis right hey if your momma has
a penis and she's offended I don't care
that's oh you can just walk here no you
can't well that's fantastic have to walk
back you have to work back beauty hey
let's watch PewDiePie be pissed for five
hours that's fun yay yay alright
f mother [ __ ] saved I'm glad I saved
all right is that mutt okay okay okay is
there a quick load feature
I don't dare try to press anything I
just feel like it will delete
all right
all right yes [ __ ]
okay yes haha I did that what's going on
over here I bet there's things to chop
dramatic open door in slow motion I
don't like that check this out first
hey I haven't already been here
I have [ __ ] alright shotgun come at me
bro oh okay we're good
fair enough what I'm back here is this
it are you [ __ ] mean my I don't like
this anymore I'm sad now let's hide in
the cupcake
stop shouting me I'm just a map out fine
keep shooting me right yeah that's cool
I thought I opened like thing between
the thing
but apparently not no I didn't quit bruh
[ __ ] Super Mario [ __ ] your dad your
[ __ ] Super Mario [ __ ]
alright what's going on here that's my
dad again I need it back by a bath
alright I need a quick say cuz I'm gonna
die tough what's up there
alright top top top to top please let
this be chopper ball come on be shot
football ah god damn it's not chopper
ball alright it's time to use this
alright come on come on quick
[ __ ] okey Psylocke's good found the D
section yeah all right we have three
shots of ammo and I just needed one all
right well that's there's another one
alright he just wanted to squirrel
before a night I kidding oh yes haha
quick say all got them all right it's my
own [ __ ] my LeBeau but what all right
I'm outta here
where's the D section I know of course
of course it's something here and I'm
gonna hit hit rose like a favorite if
you enjoyed subscribe to come over okay
and I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]